side here you see these beautiful birds
although they're called Canada geese we
locally refer to them as ninja swans the
security of the river can huh
interesting facts uh Prince Charles
studies at Cambridge with the lower
seven grades in human history in 1961
the queen bribed 3.5 million pounds so
we can study it there's one point
yeah behind me to my right side there's
a student accommodation it looks like
Hogwarts is working looks like Hogwarts
that's amazing they're all bedroom
windows yeah so rent a room there today
there's 390 pounds per month
well that was last summer when I asked
six students
well the hot sun is there you'll see an
abundance of students some with beers
and pizzas